what if one Zone on your sprinkler
system isn't coming on or isn't shutting
off but the rest of your system's
working just fine it could be your valve
it could be your controller or it could
be your wiring how do you tell which
today we're going to use a volt meter to
troubleshoot your malfunctioning Zone
Dwayne Smith here your sprinkler
Warehouse product specialist let's
figure out what's wrong with that zone
[Music]
troubleshoot some of the electrical
components you're going to need either a
multimeter also called a voltmeter or a
solenoid activator chatterer for this
video we'll be using the volt meter we
have an almost identical video to this
one where we go through the same process
using a Pro 50 activator chatterer if
you have an activator or chatter you
should check out that video instead of
this one so let's start troubleshooting
problem one a zone won't stop running
that kind of issue is something that
would probably not be caused by a
controller it's nearly certain that's a
valve issue let's talk about what that
looks like if your Zone should not be on
but the sprinklers in that zone are on
or they're sort of on by that I mean
maybe you've got water dribbling from
the top of several heads or a few heads
are popping up and not just for a few
minutes after the Zone shuts off it's
happening continuously then the valve
for that zone is not closing all the way
so in that case find and replace the
valve problem two one zone isn't coming
on all the way that may look like
several heads and not popping up perhaps
none of them are but there's water
seeping from the top of some of the
heads then most likely your valve isn't
opening all the way you probably need to
find and replace that valve problem
three one zone won't come on at all this
is the most difficult problem to
diagnose I have seen one case where
customers module was not seated properly
and there was an error code on the front
of the controller if you have a modular
controller make sure that the module is
inserted properly and locked into place
also make sure it's not a programming
error go through the program to
determine that the zone is scheduled to
run and for how long you can run a
manual cycle and Skip ahead to that zone
most controllers will have some sort of
indicator on the screen to show that a
Zone should be on if the controller is
showing that the zones should be running
but the sprinklers in that zone are not
coming on at all this could be a problem
with the controller itself the wiring
between the controller and the valve or
the solenoid on the valve you're going
to have to do some electrical
troubleshooting let's talk briefly about
what happens when a controller activates
a valve to activate a Zone the
controller sends 24 volts of electricity
through a lead wire to the solenoid on
the valve the solenoid is connected to
both a lead wire and to the common wire
common wire is also connected to all the
valves in your system and heads back to
the controller that completes the
circuit when the solenoid is activated
it opens up the valve sending water to
the sprinklers
so let's check to see if the controller
is working properly grab your multimeter
set it to test for around 24 volts ac
so we're testing for voltage here not
current and by the way testing the
voltage only works on a regular system
it isn't going to work on a battery
operated controller so set the
controller to run the problem Zone
and then you're going to place the black
rope to the common terminal on your
controller and then touch the red probe
to the Zone that's running you should be
getting a reading of somewhere between
20 and 30 volts here I'm getting around
25 so that's good if your reading is
really low your controller is
malfunctioning or if you have a modular
controller it could be that just the
module is bad you could try replacing
that module if you have another terminal
that's not being used you could switch
the wire from the non-working Zone to
the available terminal and reprogram the
controller to run that zone instead even
if you can't make that work you will
probably still have to replace the
controller eventually if you don't have
another terminal available and assuming
it's not a module issue you need a new
controller it's a great time to upgrade
if you've got a basic model you might
want to check out a smart controller
that can change its programming based on
local weather stations and you can
program it with your smartphone check
out the choices on
sprinklerwarehouse.com if however your
controller checks out fine turn off the
zone
turn the meter to measure resistance you
want to set it to the lowest resistance
range touch the common terminal and the
terminal of the Zone you're testing
touch or wrap the wires to the probes
the proper amount of resistance should
fall somewhere between 20 and 60 ohms
depending on the brand and model of
valve if your valve has a DC latching
solenoid which is what you will have if
your controller is battery operated you
should get a reading of around 5 ohms
depending on the brand if you get a
reading of 1 or ol that is you're
getting the exact same reading as when
the probes aren't touching anything or
you're getting something below 20 ohms
then you've got a broken wire an
unconnected wire or a bad solenoid so
let's narrow down the problem further
The Next Step will have to happen at the
valve you'll need to locate your valve
box
at the valve box unhook the wires on the
solenoid
with your multimeter set to test
resistance touch or wrap the wires
coming from the solenoid to your probes
does not matter which wire goes to which
probe
to have a reading of between 20 to 60
ohms if the reading Falls outside of
that you've got a problem
most valve manufacturers make resistance
specs available online once again if you
get a one or an ol reading or you get a
reading close to zero you've got a bad
solenoid now a solenoid by itself often
costs nearly as much as a new valve so
you might as well change out the valve
the valve will eventually wear out so if
you get a new valve in place you
probably won't have to touch the Bow Box
again for years
if your solenoid tested good you
probably have a wiring problem so let's
check that set the controller to run on
the Zone you're testing set your
multimeter to check for around 24 volts
ac touch or wrap the wires to the probes
on your multimeter and look for a
reading of somewhere between 20 and 30
volts if you're getting a reading of
somewhere around zero or pretty low the
problem is your wiring if your wiring is
bad check if a wire connector has come
off or see if there's a spot where the
wire has become corroded at the wire
connector hopefully that's your problem
if that doesn't fix it you may need to
run new wire if you happen to have
multi-strand wire coming into the valve
and one of the strands in the multi-wear
is not being used just swap to an unused
wire and swap the wire at the controller
running wire is a lot of work so if
there's another valve nearby maybe even
a valve in the same valve box an option
would be to purchase a doubler a doubler
will allow you to operate two valves
using only one lead wire so that's a
possible solution hope this helps
questions chat with one of our
incredible customer service agents on
sprinklerwarehouse.com they really do
know their stuff and they'll get you
squared away get everything you need for
that next landscape project from
sprinkler Warehouse a proud member of
the Heritage Landscape Supply Group your
success is our heritage sprinkler
Warehouse America's most shop sprinkler
store subscribe to our YouTube channel
for helpful tips tutorials and general
sprinkler instruction
foreign